i have a theory i was thinking about
this
why is trump launching these lawsuits
that seem to be
almost frivolous and historically even
though he talks a lot about
launching lawsuits like he said he was
going to sue rosie o'donnell famously
back when they had their feud and if you
go back and look at the clips they're
hilarious
um but he never does it right so this is
unusual
trump refuses to concede but then he
launches a whole bunch of lawsuits
some of which i think the arguments make
sense i was i was reading uh
you know the way it was described by
several different law scholars through
various publications was
three hail marys that trump would have
has these arguments that are kind of
ridiculous long shots
so we saw rudy giuliani was uh uh was
litigating today for on behalf of trump
or whatever whatever the phrase i don't
know he was testifying or it's not a
criminal
civil yeah so he was arguing you know
we've got 682 000 ballots that weren't
properly observed
and the judge is basically like what am
i supposed to do disenfranchise the
whole state this is crazy
and so a lot of people have been mocking
the trump campaign these long shots will
never win
maybe they never were supposed to win
maybe maybe the lawsuits were just meant
to give trump an excuse as to why he's
not conceding
think about this way if trump doesn't
concede
and the race is called for joe biden 306
to 232
and then trump just says oh by the way
i'm not going to concede i'm also not
doing anything else
i'm going to wait yeah and then all of a
sudden the republicans
in michigan say we're not going to
certify this and then trump goes oh gee
oh look at that
it's going to be really weird people are
going to be like what is this trump
refused to concede waited and the
republicans
didn't certify he was planning this
right it was a scheme the whole time
yeah
i'm not saying that trump actually
conspired any such way but i will say
maybe
it's because other people have suggested
you know on the left that trump's
lawsuits are
like meritless what's he doing maybe he
was just buying time to get to the
certification process
and then one by one the states refused
to certify and then trump
that's it with this announcement that
the wayne county board is not going to
certify
trump no longer needs any lawsuits he
can simply say
did you see what happened in in detroit
wait have you looked at his twitter feed
has he
addressed this this should look at that
this is such an interesting precedent
because i think that once michigan does
this all these other states are going to
feel a little more comfortable to be
like yeah it's like a domino figure
exactly our election isn't quite on
either maybe we're going to have to do
what michigan did
i don't know just spitballing i have no
idea i think you're right that he's
buying time
i think you're i think i think so too
also he's using taxpayer money to fund
these lawsuits right
he didn't tweet about it but what else
is interesting is that he is giving his
base what he what they want which is a
finger to the media
right the media told them sit down and
shut up submit
and he's like yeah no we're not going to
do that and it's going to drive people
that you hate crazy
and that's joe biden is joe biden kamala
harris
they're a lot less upset about this than
people like don lemon and chris cuomo
why didn't kamala harris
resign from the senate that's such a
good question she gets it
is this a punch line no i it's a
legitimate question she has not yet
resigned her assignment because she
couldn't figure out how to unlock her
pen
i don't know she's waiting until the
last minute but so
uh what was it obama who resigned almost
immediately
i think so pence didn't though right
they're they're taking but
i'm not saying she has to or she does
i'm saying she's taking it seriously
that
trump might win yeah for sure so here's
what i'm saying what's not i don't think
that's true i think there might be some
votes that are very close between now
and january the republicans might do
some shenanigans so she doesn't want to
lose that seat right exactly
yeah if trump wins no but even if trump
the point being like the republicans
have the senate majority
if she leaves the senate they're the
democrats she's down one vote
right and they're they might be trying
to pull that's true
regarding trump and not following
through with lawsuits before i was
thinking because it was would have been
private lawsuits he'd actually pay for
the rosio donald thing out of his own
pocket but i think the taxpayers are
paying for these lawsuits of his right
now
now he's funding them personally oh yes
and he's raising money for it for him
coming from his campaign or whatever so
what i'm saying is right now
trump he's not tweeting about it he says
oh whoa
breaking news what i just tweeted about
this are you messing with me no second
georgia county finds thousands more
votes majority for trump
this is crazy is this happening
this is the listen listen listen listen
hold on thank you
ron first of all trump's trump's not
tweeting
about michigan he's not why not
distracting you with george yes
yes he's not just that he fired krebs
because the real strategy is stuff to do
one by one
the republican boards won't certify
maybe it won't happen maybe it's just
wishful thinking i have no idea
guys we're forgetting hillary clinton
might still become president and here's
how
no no michael so what is this it's her
turn she just gotta get in her broom oh
my gosh check this out a second county
in georgia has found a memory card with
thousands of votes that have not been
uploaded
the majority of which were for donald
trump no evidence there's no
evidence no evidence gabriel sterling
i say this is a russian who's
misinformed okay thank you thank you
michael
hold on what's the number wow this is
this is insane
do you know that i hate chaos it makes
me uncomfortable
you know when i play when i when i play
magic i'm all about red and blue
uh for those not familiar it's the chaos
colors but uh anyway i digress
did you know that 800 2600 votes being
found
is like historical so i'm reading all
these articles
you know i think with scott walker who
tweeted in recounts you typically find a
hundred a couple hundred votes there's
no way trump is going to overcome these
odds in a place like georgia
georgia's down it's the lead is like 13
000.
now they found in what was it was it
fulton county they found 2
600 votes uncounted 800 net gain for
trump
that is the second highest according to
a bunch of these articles where they
said the most we've ever seen was in
florida
they did the recount with a bunch of
different counties and then uh
gorg ended up gaining like 1300 and they
said that was massive
now they're saying they found 800 for
trump in a recount
now they're saying they found thousands
more this is historically unprecedented
as far as i know
but it's also historically largely
unprecedented
for the media to insist on not
looking into things about elections yeah
for the media to insist
it's over we called it the when kaylee
mcany white house press secretary
a fox news uh you know pulled they're
like oh we can't be
repeating what she's saying let's have
kabuto pulled away let's pretend
for the sake of argument that she's
saying complete lies and misinformation
it is very important if the white house
press secretary
who is speaking for the president is
lying to the american public
so we for us to hear what she's saying
now you can go after that and give
context and be like
here's why she's lying and this is wrong
but to not let you hear
what is coming out of the white house i
don't think anyone who's a historic
leftist
would like corporate media to have that
kind of power over the government
this was floyd county where they found
800 they've now found a total of 1
500 and it's called floyd county the
irony if there's a george county this is
gonna be amazing yeah no so so the
second one is fayette county
they found 1577 for trump and 1128 for
biden
biden's statewide advantage is now down
to 12 929
in two counties they found these missing
votes
trump just jumped on a memory card on
different memory cards that weren't
being uploaded what
how do you i'm sorry okay let's i'm not
gonna get
i have my alex jones tinfoil hat in my
house i might put it on ebay
the point being if i'm if i'm working
for
the uh county if i'm trying to get votes
counted
how are there not contingencies to make
sure
that things are uploaded in more than
one location there's backups
especially when dealing about thousands
of votes like regardless of who you want
to be in the presidency
like this is the kind of thing where
systems have to be in place so the human
error is not possible this is very known
like this is why you balance a checkbook
yep this is crazy what
there's more are you messing am i being
true i'm not i'm not i'm not telling you
i hate trolling
the recovered votes may also help uh
david perdue running for senate
get the 50 yes and then he wins
see you knew i knew what get to 50
yeah they found ballots and they say
he's uh
he's very close he's 14 000 votes away
from securing 50 percent and then
keeping the senate could you imagine
trump wins
republican maintain republicans who
maintain control the senate gain in the
house
all these all of these biden people and
trump people who are dancing in the
street are going to have the biggest
collective meltdown we've ever seen in
our lives
maybe it won't happen but at this point
i'm just i'm done i've been saying for a
while i think biden's gonna win it's the
most likely i'm out
sorry no i have no idea what's gonna
happen i could be trump this is this is
crazy stuff
look when when i first when i heard when
when lydia shows me the phone
that wayne county's refusing to certify
the results we could throw the
could throw the whole state into
question i'm like no way
can is this going to happen again i kind
of feel like it might
never the clark county thing in nevada
suit going on in pennsylvania who knows
do you know what this is then then i see
this this thing about the votes second
county this is unprecedented
do you know what's going to happen if
anything like this happens they're going
to
do everything in their power to kick out
the electoral college
yeah because they're going to be like we
can't have this trust the states to run
their own elections
we need to have a national popular vote
they're going to put their foot on the
accelerator as fast as they can they're
going to call for ending
they've already been calling for ending
the constitution they're going to say
this is a ridiculous process that makes
no sense not the constitution but for
college
no i'm saying the constitution who's
calling for ending the constitution the
new republic wrote an article saying the
left needs to fight to end the written
constitution
no i'm not kidding oh 100 percent what
are you talking about though
what do you mean talking about they say
the villains need to destroy the
constitution
they said it was an article the new
republic is a leftist publication it's a
very prominent one
and they said it's time for the left to
start fighting to end the conflict but
it wasn't like a
someone in in the senate that wanted to
do no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no just left
us but this is their craziness
yeah exactly saying it's crazy crazy has
no meaning in politics it's just me i
mean
if you're crazy if you're crazy of power
you can do whatever you want the
constitution
is making it so that trump might
actually have lost the popular vote
and the electoral college but still
result in trump winning the presidency
and they're going to argue against the
electoral college as the founding
fathers wanted
i mean to an extent yeah absolutely
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you